never has an experiment for vaccine
being more eagerly anticipated one that
could not only prevent deaths from
coronavirus but return our lives to
normal ELISA is the first of more than
5,000 volunteers who have the jab called
Chad ox1 over the next five months as
part of clinical trials to confirm
whether it's safe and effective I'm a
scientist so of course I want to try and
support science the scientific process
whenever I can and since I don't study
viruses I felt a bit useless these days
though I felt like this is a very easy
way for me to support the cause
scientists at Oxford University have
combined some of the coronaviruses
genetic material with a harmless version
of a common cold virus which is highly
effective at infecting human cells and
stimulating an immune response
one of the senior scientists told me
it's proven technology already used to
make vaccines against Ebola and several
other diseases there is a lot of
expectation on waiting for a vaccine and
I generally think that this vaccine has
an extremely strong chance of working
compared to many of the other
technologies that are out there
Manufacturing could also be a challenge
Sky News was given rare access to one of
the factories now grappling with the
problem of making 1 million doses by
September while clinical trials are
still underway there's no guarantee
they'll be able to scale up production
what normally takes five years of trial
and error for a new vaccine is being
done in just five months the real
challenge with this situation is fast
track it's a - per doses and we really
need to be in a position where we can
deliver those doses for clinical trials
and hopefully approval
by the end of the year until three weeks
ago this was just a green grassy field
millions more doses will be needed
Construction has just started on a
government-funded vaccine manufacturing
center with the capacity to make one
dose for every person in the country in
just four months but it won't be ready
until next summer what has been the
delay and why couldn't we have done it
sooner well I think actually the the
government was fairly forward-thinking
on this compared to other other
countries so you know within Europe this
is the only type of facility of its sort
and you know nobody could predict that
that Kovach 19 was going to come along
in the way when it did if it had been
two years later the facility would have
been here and we'd all have been ready
it's barely four months since a totally
new virus began spreading in China yet
already scientists have an experimental
vaccine to test on volunteers we can but
hope Thomas More Sky News in Oxford